[Applause]
you heard about brad pitt's new girl oh
he's sharing a [ __ ] yeah she's married
but it's an open relationship
and i don't know who said maybe alexis
guerrero is like can you imagine being
that husband
like you probably like i'm in an open
relationship i'm about to [ __ ] everybody
i'm winning
and then she has a brad [ __ ] pit
and you're just like oh my god dawg
worst case scenario you know where she
met him
huh at her husband's [ __ ]
restaurant wow
that's violence he's disrespectful now
there gotta be some rules with that's
violation bro disrespectful you're not
gonna meet
my wife i got a different take on this
one say again i got a different take on
this okay go
i think old dude's bragging yep
i think would this be the first time if
your wife was dating brad pitt would be
the first time you ever wanted a woman
to get pregnant
shut up
bullets in your [ __ ] that's mark this is
mark
me already son right in my [ __ ] hair
that [ __ ] hurted but dude gets to brag
like this is his fifth you really think
he's bragging to the homies like you
know what my wife's doing right now
throating brad ah my wife's so hot that
brad pitt wants her
not wants her is digging her out and
coming inside of her
so what they have an open marriage so
he's
haven't opened her open in that way
try to keep it open when we say open
it means i'm open for business and you
have very minimal hours how do they not
understand this
yeah this is a one-way street the open
relationship walmart you
office hours you mom and pop shop
lollipop
yeah stop it with this [ __ ] brad pitt
that's it's disrespectful honestly yeah
you were trying to say before that brad
pitt was getting the short end of the
stick
oh yeah brad now brad pitt gotta share
[ __ ] with this that's what i'm
saying eight years old from germany way
worse on brad than it is on the other
dude
it's pathetic all parties involved
except this girl who looks mad
regular in the instagrams that i already
masturbated
you know what i'm saying i don't think i
don't think brad pitt's sharon
that's a good pick i got the best pick i
got the best picture now it's a great
pick
brad pizz not sure brad looking official
yeah
oh i thought we were talking about brad
what was talking about who's that other
[ __ ]
i don't think he's sharing her he's
leasing her
oh
keep it going
[Laughter]
it's a live action event it is yes dude
you were saying
before this can't save them [ __ ]
muslims out there
what about muslim what about that
how do you feel about that
[ __ ] [ __ ] you were saying before
that
that they were sharing i don't think
they're sharing i think she's with brad
pitt until he's like all right
we're done and then she's gonna go back
to homie that's a fact if you're brad
pitt you don't give a [ __ ]
what he's saying is brad took her
yeah and is keeping her until he's done
yeah
i think that she goes back home to the
16 hour journey even better
i get to [ __ ] you and then you go get he
gets all the married [ __ ]
that's great no no no explain what
you're saying again you're saying brad
and her are now in a relationship and
the german dude gets nothing
until brad is finished no i don't think
that's it i think he's going back home i
agree with akash
what do you think the german dude's
winning son
i mean clearly he's winning also keep in
mind the german guy is like 70.
that's what i'm saying he eats on his
fifth amount
he shot his fifth marriage yeah and it's
open
he's not trying to [ __ ] he's pounding
out when hit whenever he can get it up
so it's like he got a little bit he's
gonna ship to germany al
hey you're right he's still gotta just
like hey i need to rest up
go get piped out for a little bit and
then come back when i'm ready
but how much can brad pipe he's 53 years
old
more than a 70 year old i bet breaking
pipe yo you think brad got good dick
game be
honest yo all right let me open my legs
for this conversation
i bet that [ __ ] is fantastic yo now real
talk you think brad delivers good deals
giving them guts
can i can i make an argument why not i
think no
fine ass girls beautiful ass girls
what [ __ ] trash sometimes bro
scoreboard
starfish i see why you guys didn't want
to say that out loud
no no but i mean that like i disagreed
[Music]
you're not talking about like i'm
talking about these like instagram daddy
mcdonald's
all that yeah yeah all they care about
is the way they look
etc no personality nothing right yeah
they
don't you feel like in my experience
they've been i in bed
yeah instagram thoughts got the words
dick the worst
[ __ ] what i don't know but
brad pitt is basically that no but he
got some talent to him ocean's eleven
fantastic movie
no he's talented he has no need to
please anybody he got no need to please
he don't he he you know what i mean he's
not trying to get on that back you give
him a give it out back
[Music]
yeah you know what i'm saying that's
true that's true
i feel like [ __ ] brad is the treat in
and of itself
exactly he feels the same way yeah so he
might not be delivering the dick the way
a 68 year old german man might
that 68 year old german man is
do you think they even allow their dicks
to get hard
or do they keep it pointing down when
it's hard in germany are they just too
scary
just go straight up just go straight the
second that should start to go ah nine
nine nine not again never forget
never again never again whatever
you